[Music]
all right so i'm back from texas again
and um it's getting a little cluttered
around here i'm on a mission this week
to clean up this town and there's only
one man standing in my way and his
name's nico i used to really struggle to
throw things away but you have to
remember that when we started cordova
digital two-day shipping wasn't a thing
and so when we did something quick the
only way to have it quick was to have it
on hand i know it's been a little uh oh
nick's here too shoot
he has a lot to say on the matter we're
gonna have to reorganize and maybe get
rid of some things a little robot this
is robot i forget his actual name i made
him for the game battleborn and it took
me like two days to build this guy and
paint him jake thinks robot doesn't add
anything of value to the studio
i think robot is one of the coolest
props honestly the robot's the most nice
things like show off when we come into
like the back area and we show all the
props like the gun wall everybody goes
what they see the gumball
what
yes what about that
it's the one thing people take instagram
pictures with in their studio i'm not
gonna give a tour anymore if there's no
gun wall what are we gonna show jake
there's nothing here's where our dumb
batteries charge can we go down there do
people do electric skateboarding anymore
no way so 2015. useless
dope
this is chaos how do we even use this
you don't know when you're going to eat
a box of bees
[Music]
i don't even know like what's in there
what is that
oh it's a flake stand that's from the
secret service cat
i'll make the ultimate sacrifice okay
not i'm not gonna kill myself
hi
jake watson esquire esquire
we'll chop up the guillotine and get rid
of it just like i built robot jake built
this guillotine with his own two hands
and now that he's considering destroying
it i am questioning his decision making
my eight ball this is how i used to make
decisions eight ball do i chop up the
guillotine
yes
eight
definitely
see this is actually this this i kept
this apart because it actually worked
right he says yes
i'm gonna ask an important question as
important as the gate well only i can
use the eight ball oh okay well they're
asking about the gun wall oh eight ball
should we keep the gun wall
ask again later
eight ball no no no no no no you have to
ask later listen to the eight ball okay
eight ball
should we
keep
nick's robot
oh
okay
you may rely on it
i've always been able to rely on you
buddy
should we go through this entire problem
and get rid of
many things
it is certain
remember we made that video for the
quarter crew channel where we just laid
out all our nerf guns yeah
that got like more views than all of our
victims we find that here
feels like my first day here organizing
these men's toys
[Music]
vintage nerf guns get a final test
this one passed the test here's my
camera mount actually i mean this is a
good piece of camera gear just notice
how the guts to use it here look what i
just found the prison actually this is
the prototype prism from prison from
prism how long has that been just on the
shelf under nerf guns probably for 10
years
whoa we got mini guns we can make a
miniature version of the gun wall right
here we would look so big
all right we're going to open this door
up
[Music]
see all of ren's old like sam and nico
channel like energy has come back out
now oh my god
exactly what's happening right now this
is my first 3d printer we had a whole
video about it
oh my god jesus
[Music]
i know dean wants to make a nerf angel
he's just too scared to ask come on make
a nerf angel
oh my back dude
that was from the lynx shadow video we
did that was like nine years ago i just
had a junk ball that's against the rules
that's a jump ball that's against the
rules this is the minecraft pickaxe man
i remember pulled up in my minivan and
you guys just filled it up with these
cardboard janky ass costumes that axe
was there dude the original dubstep gun
that goes in the museum the hall of fame
i'm a nostalgic person it's my i think
partly my fascination with history but
also
you can't throw away those those really
iconic props you know
someday they may be worth something more
than just sentimentally
[Music]
and if earth was scaled down to the size
of this the death star would be as big
as an airsoft bb
i actually like organizing stuff this is
all the space we have for the next
probably two years so we just need to be
comfortable in the space that we have
utilize it better with the pace that we
move at if you can't access something
almost immediately it's as if you don't
have it i called a little towing junk
company they're gonna come and get rid
of all this stuff we're here to donate
all this stuff right here for some kids
oh man if i was a kid
and i found all this stuff bro
be wildy man cool guns
shoes well this is awesome
the guillotine is going to come down
today right now i kept it for as long as
i could with the dream that maybe one
day i'd
you know revive the channel but let's be
honest we are gathered here today to
witness the last breath of our
guillotine friend just because something
destroys
humans and chops heads off it doesn't
mean it can't make really precious
memories and create friendships along
the way and that's what the guillotine
did you know it's important to care
about objects i'm not immune to it at
all the object of the studio itself
is nostalgic to me you owe it to the
space that you're in to make sure that
there's always room for something new
it's the end of an era but you know what
this means it means that there's another
one coming it's hard for me to let go of
things that have memories attached to
them but at the same time we do have
hundreds of videos that document
all those memories and those are there
to stay
now that we have some space we can
finally build the biggest green screen
we've ever had in the studio oh my god
every single thing in this entire studio
is covered in dust dude it's on the
couch on the controllers it's in the
cameras in the computers so we had a
render going last night with sucking air
how are we going to clean all this
[Music]
is our equipment room forever sign up at
corridor digital.com and watch crew cuts
to find out our website subscribers get
episodes like this
twice a week and they answer all of your
burning questions what's going on with
son of a dungeon are we secretly making
a show for netflix why is peter in the
suit of armor who is that what is this
and why is there spaghetti hidden all
over the studio
crew cuts on corridor digital.com it's
like youtube but better
garbage pile's there
[Applause]
work smarter not harder
didn't work
dude i'm peeling back the sedimentary
layers back here
wow that saved me so much effort